hey guys now beards have gone in and out
of style over the last few decades but
in recent years they came back in full
force and in a lot of different styles
but not every guy out there can grow a
beard and why is that what is the real
reason for it because I've seen a lot of
you guys ask me this in the comment
sections of some of my videos so that's
what I'm gonna talk about in this video
but if it's your first time here
subscribe and also click that
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next videos and then welcome to D
LM model lifestyle know now talking
let's start with the video so why can't
some men grow a beard well some guys out
there say hey it's because you're not
manly enough is that true well
definitely not and some other guys say
it's because your testosterone I mean
testosterone is not high enough is that
true well no definitely not so what is
it why can't some men grow a beard well
the reason is this your beard is
produced by D hydro testosterone poof
what a word anyway which is synthesized
from testosterone so in other words that
means the ability to grow a beard does
not depend on testosterone but how your
body reacts to the testosterone so it
all comes down to your genes now this
means that men who are more sensitive
like myself to testosterone are also
likely to lose their hair in other words
to go bald so if you can't grow a beard
it's not all that bad because chances
are you were not gonna go bold like your
bearded friends or maybe like me
I don't know so in short if you go bald
then chances are you'll be able to grow
a badass beard but if not if you can't
grow a beard chances are you won't get
bald so it's like a win-win or a
lose-lose it depends on how you look at
it if you like if you don't give it a
thumbs up subscribe and we will talk
soon
[Music]